Now, before we go any further, you should make sure your computer can run WebGL
programs. Gl stands for Graphics Library and it's what this course uses to teach
3D Graphics. Webgl is built into a number of web browsers so you don't need to
install anything. Unfortunately there's one major exception, Internet Explorer.
So, you'll need to use a different browser such as Chrome or Firefox. On Macs,
Safari supports WebGL but you'll have to do a little twiddle to enable it. Linux
has it's own issues. You may also have problems with older graphics cards and
drivers. The easiest way to test and debug your computer is to visit the
following url, get.webgl.org. If you see a simple rotating cube on the screen
you're all set. If not follow the instructions on this webpage to get your
computer properly set up. If one browser doesn't work for you try another. My
personal preference is Google's Chrome as it has a java script debugger built
in. If you get stuck, see the additional course materials for more tips and
suggestions. Ultimately, you have to get WebGL to work, in order to fully enjoy
this course. Once you have it set up, you can go to a huge number of web pages
that have graphical demos running on them, like this one. Look at the links
provided for some of the better programs out there.